they call themselves long-haulers or
long-tailers
some have been sick almost as long as
the new coronavirus has been around
covert 19 is causing more long-term
damage than thought
as i was diagnosed with some blood clots
smaller blood clots in both my lungs
then i got a lot of respiratory problems
the doctors just do not understand why
i've still got blood clots
but i want them to find out what's going
on
after covered 19 i lost almost half my
hair
we hope we majority of the lesser
symptoms will disappear after a time
but as with the first sars pandemic
we'll almost certainly witness permanent
health issues
but to what extent is unknown thousands
of people of all ages
are staying sick for weeks even months a
study by denmark's ahus university found
a third of corona patients suffered
long-term side effects
for some the virus just comes and goes
or just doesn't go rather it stays the
disease can damage
the lungs heart and brain increasing the
risk of long-term health problems
susanna helferich and her husband peter
kuhn
were among the first people in germany
to contract the coronavirus back in
march
as they emerged from quarantine two
weeks later
they thought everything would be fine
but we were wrong because even now
five months later susanna helfer is
still suffering from the effects of the
virus
before she was very active and highly
sporty
that's all changed as you can see
i'm very tired i can easily go to bed
and fall asleep at eight o'clock
that wasn't the case before and that's
the main problem the tiredness
it's really debilitating she's not alone
many doctors say they see patients who
are struggling to fully recover
after an acute coronavirus infection
we're seeing patients who are dogged by
health problems for weeks even months
afterwards
even though the virus is no longer
present and they should actually be
healthy again
nicole haskell also suffers from
exhaustion
during her illness with coronavirus she
lost her sense of taste
and smell three months later she can
still barely smell
anything not even her morning coffee
it's very limiting because i can't
really explain it it's something that
really affects my quality of life
the cause could be an impairment in the
olfactory bulb
during the sars outbreak in 2002
experiments on animals showed the virus
could work its way through the nerve
endings in the linings of the nose and
the olfactory nerve
to the brain's olfactory system before
heading on
over the synapses it's likely that this
can also occur with covid19
it's can't particularly sign that's all
it could be that some of these patients
have actually suffered some brain damage
because with patients who present only
with impairments to their senses of
taste and smell
which is a common neurological symptom
when we investigate them with mr imaging
we can see damage to the olfactory bulb
the psychological stress caused by the
pandemic could play a role too
nicole husker hopes she'll one day
return to her old self
but she says her brother's experience
has scared her
my brother didn't have any proper
symptoms and he's only started to feel
really bad since he recovered
he has pains in his joints his knees
really hurt
he constantly has the feeling that he's
out of breath
as yet no one knows what is actually
causing such symptoms
or how long they could go on for
researchers across the globe are working
to come up with answers
but it'll be some time before they have
them
oliver coast joins us from the
university of gottingen where he's a
senior physician
great to have you on the show you found
covert 19 can affect the kidneys early
on
and that can be detected detected in a
urine sample what's that mean for the
course of the disease
yes indeed well we know that a subgroup
of
patients with coping 19 gets sicker than
others
so days after onset of the symptoms
we know that some need icu care
and have a high mortality so our idea
actually was to to use the urine to
identify the subgroup earlier in terms
of well once the urine gets
positive in terms of multi-organ
infection
it tells us that this patient is at risk
so actually use this urine sample
to to identify you as a multi-organ
failure patient address so this is a
good warning sign of a
of a serious infection are there other
warning signs too
yes i i think there are um however if
you
imagine yourself being infected as a
copit 19 patient being at home
in quarantine it is hard for your family
doctor to check you
every day for all different signs of
organ failure so if you use this urine
dipstick it's easy to use like a
pregnancy test
um it makes it a lot easier for your
family doctor
to to identify your earlier that you are
at risk
um so once you are identified
the the family doctor will take a closer
look or even transfer you to the
hospital what about knowing yourself
whether whether or not you're at risk
before it even gets
that far i mean some people have mild
symptoms some have none others get
really sick does it
does it all come down to how healthy we
are
um it's a very good question that is
very hard to answer because we are still
in the learning phase
in incorporate 19 and data are confusing
everywhere in the world so let me pick
two factors that i think are
quite important here the first factor is
bad luck
so if you are a male in your 50s or
60s and if your
immune system is simply over x and we
don't know why
some immune systems overact
you become seriously ill some other
factors of course are
being overweight being a smoker and that
that also play a role here and the
second i think even more important
factor is exposure and so the higher the
virus load you are exposed to the higher
your risk
is um so think of
this people being in
operation parties um they really had a
high exposure
um and by the way the the highest
exposure actually have
the healthcare workers at the emergency
departments and
icu's being exposed to severely ill
patients so please be aware that the
healthcare workers are
at the highest risk yeah definitely um
when it comes back to the the patient if
if they tickle the boxers and are sure
to get
seriously ill what measures can you take
um well just to make sure that this is
not an official recommendation
by myself or the university
hospital so my personal opinion here is
well if our algorithm including the
urine dipstick tells you that this
patient is at risk i would consider two
points the
the first point is to um anti-coagulate
yourself
more aggressively to to prevent trauma
embolic events because
we know that trump embolic events are
major killer in the setting
and the second point is that once you
you are at risk to deteriorate
it would be very tempting to start the
anti-viral
medications we actually have earlier
before
you get sicker briefly
as far as the length of time that
patients can suffer is it possible to
predict the extent
of damage
um we simply do not know
it would not be fair to give you a clear
answer here
um we just don't know enough about
the the long-term consequences of copied
19.
for sure we know
at present that this is a
multi-disciplinary
discipline we need to take care of
so we for sure need all the
internists specialties
after this infection to to make sure
that for example
the chronic renal failure you might
suffer after this
infection is detected and treated
senior physician oliver course at the
university of gottingen thank you very
much for joining us today
your turn to ask the questions if you
haven't already get in contact on our
youtube channel
we'll get our science correspondent
derek williams to look into any topics
you bring up
do people living with hiv have an
increased chance of dying from covid19
a number of different studies have
looked at this issue
and and although the data is still
pretty limited
um mostly they agree that people who are
living with hiv
and that are on an effective treatment
program with antiviral medication
are not any more likely to contract or
die from covet 19 than than people who
don't have hiv
the u.s centers for disease control
currently lists
having the immunodeficiency disease as
as only
may be affecting outcomes a key aspect
of that though
is certainly going to be whether or not
hiv patients continue to get the
antiviral therapies
that are keeping their disease in check
the united nations program that's
responsible for
for global action on hiv has warned that
in 2020 there could be up to
half a million additional aids deaths
in in sub-saharan africa alone
caused not by patients catching covet 19
but because it's disrupting supply lines
for and
and access to the medications that those
patients need to survive
that would basically wipe out all of the
progress that's been made
in the fight against aids over the last
[Music]
decade
you